So the first design alternative that we're going to
look at is using coarse grain session beans. In this
structure that I'm showing you, we're only looking at
the web container. The EJB container because, the applet container
that interfaces with the client, is in the web
browser. So we don't worry about that. We'll talk only
about how we structure the web container and the EJB
container in the different design alternatives. So the web container
contains the presentation logic and in the structure that I'm showing you a
servelet corresponds to an individual session with
a particular client. So, this box represents
a particular client. This box represents
a second client. And there's a presentation
logic commensurate with servelet one, that is
client number one. And similarly, presentation logic
commensurate with servelet two, which is client
number two. And there's a coarse grain session
bean that is associated with each of these
servelet. And in turn the, session bean corresponds
to the client that is being served through
the servelet number one. And similarly, servelet number
two is served by this session bean. And
as the name suggests, the session bean is
responsible for the specific needs of the
particular client that it is serving for
this particular session. Therefore, the session bean
will worry about the data accesses that are
needed to the database in order for the Business Logic to do its thing. So if,
let's say, we're doing an airline reservation system and if this is requesting
a particular booking, then the session bean is going to be the one that contacts
the database server in order to pull the
specific dates and airline reservation. Information that is
needed for the business logic to do
the pruning and selection commensurate with whatever this
particular client is requesting. And there are multiple
sessions that are contained in this EJB container,
depending on the number of clients that
have simultaneously temporally made requests to this particular
service. So the EJB container has to provide
some service for all the sessions that are
concurrently going on in this server. All of
the data accesses that are needed for a
particular session is taken care of by the
session bean. And therefore, the amount of help
that we need from the EJB container, in terms of services, is pretty minimal for
supporting this particular model, and, and in
fact, it is confined to any conflicts that
might arise in terms of external accesses
for satisfying the request of these different session
beans. So the EJB container service that would
be needed is primarily for coordinating, if any,
across concurrent independent sessions. An example would
be, if they want to access the same
portion of the database for writing some records.
In that case, they may need some coordination
help from the EJB container service. The
other important attribute of this structure is that
the business logic is confined to the corporate
network. It is not exposed to the outside
world because it's not contained in the web
container, it is contained in the EJB container
and therefore the business logic is not exposed
beyond the corporate network. That's a good thing. So,
the pros of this particular structure is that
you need minimal container services and also that the
business logic is not exposed to the outside
world. But the cons for this particular structure is,
this application structure is very akin to
a monolithic kernel that we've talked about
a lot. There is very limited concurrency
for accessing different parts of the database.
For instance, I mentioned that the services
provided by these giant scale services tend
to be embarrassingly parallel. So there is
a lots of opportunities for pulling in data,
example would be let's say, that the particular query is to compile demographic
distribution of all the employees in the
company. In that case, there's an opportunity
to pull in lots of data simultaneously
from the database. But unfortunately, the structure
doesn't allow you to exploit such concurrency.
So in other words, this core screen
session been structure represents a lost opportunity. For accessing and
pulling lots of data from the database in parallel for
satisfying either the same request or even concurrent requests that
may be accessing the same portions of the same database.